The game first appeared for the poor people
before rich people
Where deals are made in hundreds of millions of dollars
Brands of its clubs are worth
Billions $$
and its legends are welcomed like kings
Its players get astronomical sums
Where politicians and riches involve investments
and the economies of countries rely on it
Its club’s budgets compete large companies
With millions of workers around the world
Sponsored by large banks and famous brands
It’s a safe place for capitalists
How does football make its huge profits?
TV broadcasting rights
A giant financial cycle
that starts with paying the annual subscription
and ends in the pockets of players & clubs
The amount paid depends on the power and popularity of the league
Television networks
and Live streaming sites
such as Amazon
sign fictional contracts to buy the rights
to broadcast league matches from local federations
The money is distributed to the clubs
according to its rank
popularity and attraction to the viewer
without forgetting to deduct a portion of it for the local federations.
The English Premier League is the most expensive contract amongst world leagues
If the rights to broadcast are sold in 2019-2022 for 4.5 billion pounds
The share of Liverpool, the penultimate season titleholder, was 139 million pounds
while Norwich City, last rank, received 92 million
Match Tickets
Continuous and semi-guaranteed income
that depends on the loyalty of fans to their team
and their attendance at the stadiums
Ticket price varies amongst teams
and tournaments
In the Europe Champions League
prices become higher
according to the tournament roles
The price of a first-class ticket for the 2019 final
reached $ 667
and was sold on the black market
for thousands of dollars $$
The ticket price is sometimes used as
a pressure means on guest team fans
by raising the price
of tickets for obstructing their attendance at the stadium.
Barcelona FC
sold tickets for its matches
against Liverpool and Manchester United
in the 2019 Champions League
at the Camp Nou
for 119 Euros €
Manchester United responded similarly to the Catalan fans
in the second leg
before UEFA intervened
and it set the ceiling for the visiting fans’ ticket
at 70 Euros
But it's a little different for the local leagues
Ticket prices are set before the season begins
as annual subscriptions to members of the public
Arsenal, for example
sells tickets
taking into consideration the quality of the seat class
at an average price of £97
while the average price of a ticket for Hull City
is £36
All these guaranteed tickets profits
allowed clubs to spend hundreds of millions
to build new bigger stadiums
or expand their stadiums
Shirt Sales
It’s an important factor that clubs
rely on to supplement their treasuries with tens of millions annually
It targets the fan's admiration
for the shirt design for the new season
The percentage of sales increases according to the popularity of the team
and the weight of the names of players in its ranks
and it may become standard when the club attracts a famous or legendary player
But what followers do not know is that
clubs receive a small share of the profits from shirt sales!
Sponsors, like Adidas, Nike, and others
purchase team T-shirt rights in long-term contracts
Then T-shirts are manufactured
and sold in own and club’s stores in the world
which gives it the largest profit percentage
For example, Nike concluded a deal
with Liverpool FC over a period of 5 years
with a value of $200 million
which the club would receive a 20% commission from the sales percentage.
And if you see it as a small percentage
the surprise is that it is one of the highest commissions that a team can receive!
Commissions usually range from 7.5% to 15% max!
Financial Rewards
The more the team wins and plays better
the more profits it gets
Participation in the EU Champions League
generates fantastic profits for clubs
This participation guarantees
15 million euros for the club
Winning each match means 2.7 million Euros
& Draw means 900,000 Euros
The winner of the tournament earns 19 million Euros
which means that he may win a total prize money
about 80 million Euros
Clubs also receive good money prizes upon winning local leagues
Sponsorship Rights
Football clubs use their Shirts as a moving billboard!
And among its stadiums, as an arena for promoting the contracted brands
Real Madrid has a fictional contract with Emirates Airlines
for 5-years
where it earns $82.5 million
every season!
Followed by Tottenham contract with the insurance company AIA
with a $50 million /Season
Then Manchester United, who signed a new five-year contract
early this season with TeamViewer
and provides the club's treasury with
£ 47 million each season
Some clubs use T-shirt
to advertise slogans & brands on the sleeves or backside
Clubs sometimes take advantage of everything related to them
to the point of changing the name of their stadium!
A club like Arsenal
not only signed a sponsorship contract with Emirates Airlines
but also named its stadium "Emirates Stadium", in 2006
after buying Name Rights
until 2028!
as well as organizing a friendly tournament - Emirates Cup
Selling Players
A source that brings money for the clubs
and puts others in an economic deficit
Some clubs spend hundreds of millions annually to buy new players
Some of them write the history
and others are a disaster for the club and an economic burden
Benfica FC was the most profitable club
through selling players
In the last ten years,
players sold at £ 1 Billion
One of them is Joao Felix
who moved to Atletico Madrid
for £ 101 Million
The selling club benefits from the deal full amount
without giving anything to the sold player
unless the contract includes a sum of money called
The "Contract Bonus"
However, a club like Barcelona has spent more than
1 Billion Euros to buy new players in the last five years
3 of them cost the club's more than 400 Million Euros
in addition to their large salaries
as a result, the club entered into a financial crisis
with no solution until now
After an era when La Masia academy was a Human factory
supplying the club with the finest players
and earn large sums of money upon their sale
Sometimes, clubs get players for free!
without paying anything to the seller club
because of the expired contract
The Argentine Lionel Messi's deal
to Paris Saint-Germain is the best example of this
I mean it's unbelievable
that we have the best player in the world
at Paris Saint-Germain
for the past three days!
Calls we received from sponsors were unbelievable,
I did not expect this number!
The sources of profit are many, diverse, and uncountable
fills the pockets of the players
and load tons of money into their bank accounts!
The game was a haven for the poor people to escape from life suffering
stolen in front of their eyes
They neither afford to buy their favorite team's T-shirt
nor enter the stadium to cheer their favorite team
& some don't even have the luxury of paying a TV subscription
How long will the crazy football spending last?
Does ever a day come when we witness an economic setback into it
and bring it back to its old days?!
Football.. the  Stolen poor sport